the ukrainian ambassador to the uk is
with us here uh on the program mr
ambassador it's good to see you again
thank you very much indeed
the situation the climate has changed so
much in the couple of weeks or so that
we have been chatting maybe about three
weeks now um let's just start with those
latest figures that we've seen 90 000.
just shy of 90 000 brits have offered
their homes to ukrainian uh refugees who
are tired who are weary who are
frightened who are leaving their country
um i i just a moment ago while we were
listening to jason i said to you can you
tell me about any cultural challenges
that people might face and you laughed
you smile it's the first time i've seen
you smile in a long time i can imagine
these differences but first i would like
to tell you that we're humbled and
impressed by the numbers people opening
up their houses talking about the
differences
language is obvious reason for you know
business actually smiling but even
simple things like cuisine
it's like having french or italian in
your houses so we have differences here
but i believe that both sides will be
able to enrich their experiences
um
are you surprised that so many people
have come forward
i'm not surprised i i know that people
are very reactive to these certain
situations people opening up their
hearts and we've seen it already but the
reaction of this
some bureaucracies which you know been
we've been following all this time in in
allowing people to get here i know that
outrage people were quite unhappy that
is taken so much time now i understand
why because of this all these procedures
now i believe that everything intact so
i expected that at the end of days
people will not be just frustrated as
the bureaucrats but will do themselves
we'll take the actions as a diplomat
it's tricky for you to get involved
obviously in in in politics but do you
have a view on whether visa application
should be waived for now
i had the conversations with many
secretaries of your government which is
very great to have this access right now
when we need immediate actions and i
understand how difficult the situation
how much they have to go through uh to
get this decision i also know that after
all these waves and waves of the
immigrants these societies are strained
and this this you know all the societies
in europe they are quite uh quite have
different approach now to
refugees still very difficult for me to
attribute
world refugee to ukrainians we're still
not there yet i hope that since this
time we will have much much fluent uh
process and these kids if you probably
have seen it there's kids with the
cancer treated kids children that's
something and i also know that another
group of kids are coming here these
things you know just melt in the hearts
of the people my mind as well and those
are children also with cancer the second
group that are coming
my goodness me um how long do you
anticipate people having to stay in the
uk once they get here i know that most
of the people have to tell you about my
own family who are now in slovakia they
already wanted to get home they don't
want to go any further they already have
no stress of being exposed to the
culture was no no nothing everything
they earned over the years everything
they owned all the years is now nowhere
they have to start the new lives and
people at the
very end of their lifetime they have to
restart so they uh rather go back home
than moving any anywhere further like
like uk or other nations of the western
more western that's the thing with
refugees you know most of them don't
want to move too far away from home
they're hopeful that they'll be able to
return to their home country just as
soon as possible um it does look as
though
um the onslaught by the russians has
stalled somewhat is that reasonable
assumption
they they stopped at some at some points
but they still bombarding cities and
they start to bury more western cities
of ukraine caves and the barbados
bombardment but city like mario palette
the sea of azov is very east of ukraine
and south of ukraine the thousands of
people already killed because the
russians are besieged in very medieval
way i i you know that's very difficult
to observe and trying to help what do
you mean
barbaric
putin was so so proud of his lagging rat
where he was now at since peterborough
and it was besieged and that's not this
time they lost so many people over two
years of of this blockade now he's doing
the same to the another city of very
slavic formerly brothers you mean um
targeting hospitals targeting
residential areas they're targeting
everything and they know that they're
not allowing the food in in the city the
water in the city they're not allowing
people to get out of the city civilians
kids women everybody
i read and heard that uh people were
drinking water from their radiators
because they couldn't access water in
any other ways is that a story that
you've heard problem is that this very
sea at very seashore cities you know
water at the wells it's quite salted
already so you have to actually provide
normal potable water which was provided
through pipelines and the canals now
that most of them are cut we now have to
think in 21st century how to get water
in the city not even food
putin's aid one of putin's aides has
said that they are progressing slower
than they anticipated um
russia has looked to the chinese dragon
to support them
do you think they will
i believe the chinese are now watching
them and eyeing the siberia what they
always wanted the resources from siberia
russian they they don't believe that
russia is equal partner they wanted the
resource base for them so the china will
definitely play their own game and i see
the united states are now engaged with
china trying to understand and to you
know trying to understand where china is
right now i guess the russians won't
help much won't have much help from from
china but russia by itself is still very
dangerous to ukraine in what way
militarily they're still progressing as
you mean as you mentioned and that's
they could not have kiev in two days as
they bragged and promised they're still
moving and their machinery is still huge
we still still have to take care of the
russians we don't care about the chinese
rockets or whatever they're asking from
china
the fight is not in the air because it
doesn't seem that the russians have the
drones and the other military hardware
that they need in the air that's why
they're looking to china to try to
provide them with that as a result it's
hand-to-hand combat in places on the
ground is that what you mean when you
talk about it being barbaric
the the way the indiscriminatory
bombarding city they've been talking
about liberating ukrainians from the
some nazis governments and all this
[ __ ] now that we have to fight with
them and territorial defense just normal
folks like we
fighting for their cities and villages
so all of this and they're using the
barbaric like thermal barometric this
the weapons which are more or less
called vacuum bombs which kill everybody
in the huge in buildings and everything
they use everything against us
we know that sanctions are continuing to
increase and we'll be hearing in just a
moment or two about even more sanctions
that are being put in place
you want more than that don't you we
want everything which will allow us to
survive and with this sanctions we have
to apply more until they they stop if he
is not stopping because the sanctions
are not enough that's when we ask for so
many times we need the weapons to be
able to defend ourselves because these
are like two hands weapons and sanctions
if sanctions not working they are going
more with weapons and coming more and
sending more and more troops into
ukrainian territory we have to take care
of this part but sanctions have to hit
him hard so people of russia will tell
putin that you're actually going down
but you're pulling out putting us with
yourself we have to do something to you
know to get somehow to their heads and
minds your president um finally if i may
your president has the heart of a lion
um he is respected right around the
world most of the world at the moment we
know that he has remained in situ
in fact we saw him walking to see some
injured troops at a hospital just the
other day
as the russians move further and further
into kiev he has a decision to make
whether he stays
and fights or whether he leaves and to
fight another day what do you think
he'll do
many people would say that he had to be
moved somewhere further to carpassian
mountains putin already in europe
mountains hiding in bunker but ukrainian
leader made his mind and he mentioned it
on a number of occasions that he's
staying and fighting i know you you can
you can judge how it how it is important
for us to have a leader safe and be able
to to coordinate the effort but at the
same time he believes that what he's
what he can do he would allow military
to fight but him to you know to raise
the awareness of people he will talk to
your prime minister today and and many
leaders who came today
he is going around see he's showing
support and he's coming to the to the
wounded ones to support them as well as
families ukraine you see him ukrainians
are ready to fight
so the present president will stay and
fight to the death if necessary that's
that's what he said and that will
believe all of us okay um it's always
good to see you um i think
hopefully we'll be able to talk again
under better circumstances but for now
thank you for taking the time to join us
thank you thank you